okay good morning so welcome to the
first class of the second semester this
semester we are going to build on what
we've learned the first
semester um to better understand human
history and to better understand what's
happening in the world
today and also to be able to predict the
future okay so if you have been
following current events and I hope you
have there are now
three major
conflicts in the world the
first and most devastating is the war in
the
Ukraine where Russia and Ukraine Happ
been in
Conflict uh for about three years now
and a lot of people have
died um there's controversy over the
exact
number
but um
it's possible that over a million
soldiers have died in this war so
far and even
though president Donald Trump the United
States
has shown signs that he wants to end the
war we don't really
know when the war will end okay so this
war in in Ukraine it is still happening
and it's affecting everything and
everyone
because um obviously brings a lot of in
instability and uncertain uncertainty in
the world it's also driving up prices
and it's making things inconvenient so
when you fly United States you'll
discover that it takes you longer to fly
the United States because you can't fly
through Russia you have to fly around
Russia okay so that's the first major
conflict the second
conflict um which is not as deadly but
but which will probably prove to be even
more dangerous is the war in the Middle
East the conflict in the Middle
East um as you know um for the past
couple years Israel has been in conflict
with
basically most of its neighbors it's
launched an expedition into the Gaza
Strip against Hamas for what Hamas did
on October
7th um it's launched War a war against
Lebanon it's involved in
Syria
and the signs tell us that this conflict
will
spread Trump has come in and promise um
a resolution to the conflict but as I
will show you the semester there are
historical structural
forces that make this conflict
possibly the beginning of World War
II this conflict will only increase the
great fear right now is Israel attacks
Iran and drives United States into war
with
Iran and this will Mark the beginning of
World War II and this could possibly
lead to the end of the world as we know
it today if the United States attacks
Iran
both Russia and China must intervene in
some capacity does that make sense to
you guys Iran right now it's the Lynch
pin of the global
economy the first reason is there's a
lot of oil in Iran in the Middle
East and China South Korea and
Japan get most of its oil from the
Middle East right so if you if the oil
supply is cut off then the Chinese
economy the South Korean economy the
Japanese economy basically all East Asia
faces economic collapse and
catastrophe
okay but second is if you look at a map
Iran is really the center of the world
meaning most of the World's Trade goes
through that area especially something
called the straight of hus Iran has a
capacity uh to cut off all trade in the
shade of
hus and that would be catastrophe for
the global
economy and if that would have
happen
then the Western Powers would need to
get involved in order to free up the sh
ofus and then Russia India China who
knows okay but a lot of people would
have have to get involved in order to
protect their economic
interests all right so um I will go the
sem I will go into the
semester we'll talk a lot about what's
driving conf in the Middle East there
are these
geopolitical factors as I as I discussed
but there are Al also these religious
factors that we looked into a bit um
last semester but I will explain more
this
semester
okay and then the third and final
Conflict um is
basically the United States against the
world what I mean by that is that um
ever since the collapse of the Soviet
Union the fall of the Berlin Wall in
1991 we have been living in something
called a unipolar moment meaning there's
only one hedge one
superpower and as such the United States
has been able to dictate policy
especially Economic Policy around the
world United States controls all trade
we have to use the US dollar in order to
trade the United States also uses its
military to protect shipping
lanes and this is Crim called the Pax
Americana the American peace and this of
course has brought tremendous prosperity
to the world okay China would not have
grown as fast as China did without the
PX Americana it is American ships
American warships that allow Chinese
ships to sail safely around the world to
deliver Goods around the
world but this unipolar movement has
also created a lot of conflict
the main conflict being the United
States can invol can evade any country
for no reason 2003 it invaded Iraq for
no reason it destroyed Libya for no
reason it almost destroyed Syria for no
reason okay so the number of countries
United States has gone and destroyed are
just
staggering so and that's why Russia
under
Putin because it felt being it felt
bullied uh it felt disrespected that's
why Russia is now in conflict with the
United
States and strangely enough this
conflict has caused United States to go
into conflict
with the rest of the world okay so as
you may know United States right now
under Trump has declared or is about to
launch trade Wars against a lot of
countries
Canada
Mexico quite possibly very quickly the
the European
Union and United States is already at
economic war with Russia and
China okay so we will go in this we will
also discuss this this semester why this
is happening again my argument to you is
that if you know enough history if you
study the
historical structural forces that
drive um global conflict then you'll
understand what's going on and you'll
also be able to
predict what will
happen
okay does that make
sense
okay so um what I want to talk today is
about a new model of of historical
analysis how can we understand the
movement of History why do people do
what they do why do Nations go to war
why do Nations have
peace okay so I'm looking at Grand
history I'm looking at the uh large
structural movement of history and in
the past there have been two
main models for understanding historical
development okay so the first is the
idea of a cycle or a circle and this
makes sense right because this mirrors
what we experience in life when we we
are born but then we die and then other
people are born and then they die okay
so it's a cycle you look at the seasons
there's um winter but I gives rise to
Spring which then gives rise to Summer
then the fall then winter again it's a
cycle okay so for most of human history
most people have understood the movement
of the world as a cycle this is
certainly true in Chinese history right
um dynasties rise because because they
have the med of heaven heaven favors
some and they do justice when they first
arise but over time for for a variety of
reasons because of corruption because
it's a there's a bad
Emperor they lose Mandate of Heaven
which allows a
rebellion which then creates a new
Dynasty so a so Chinese history is
almost a continuous cycle of dynastic
rise and
decline okay now in the in the western
context there's also a cycle there are
many different Cycles but let me explain
one cycle that we've notice in the Greek
and Roman
world the cycle is this there are three
major factions in a
society there is the
people there is
nobility and then there is the king or a
great
person okay and each of these factions
have a particular Str
strength the people their strength comes
from their
numbers right they have
mass the nobility um it's only minority
of people but they have
authority they are
respected because they
know uh more they have they are better
at War than ordinary people but they
have authority okay people respect them
and the
King has the
army okay so these are the three major
forces or factions in a
society and these three factions are
always in
conflict and what happens is a changing
Alliance
where the two of the three we get
together to beat one
okay and then this forces a new alliance
right so what happens is
this you first have something call A
Anarchy where the nobility is in charge
and everyone has to do what they do what
what they command okay but over time
this arery becomes corrupt and the way
and the the way they become corrupt is
by exploiting the people through
debt all right so in a nobility the
Nobles own the land you have to work the
land but you get a share and that's
fine but sometimes the weather is bad so
you can't work the land you can't pay me
the rent so I give you a loan and over
time this loan becomes a debt
and at at a certain point you can't pay
off the debt so what happens you become
my
slave and your children become my my
slave as well okay so this creates a lot
of conflict in
society how is this conflict resolved
because one of
nobility wants to be king and he and he
sees an
opportunity in the Civil conflict
between the people and noil
nobility okay so he people if you make
me king I will clear your
debts and this creates a
monarchy and the first king is usually a
good King because he had to work hard to
obtain his
position
and um people love him for the fact that
he cleared away their debts this this is
what we call it Jubilee by the way the
word is Jubilee and this happens a lot
in human
history but the problem is the King has
a son who's not so good and then the son
has a son who's awful okay and so
nobility get angry the people get angry
and they
Rebel and they create a
democracy okay but then in the Democracy
because what happens in the democrac Y
is it's the best people or the best
speakers the wealthiest people who
control the
votes and so they get together and what
do they do they and what do they do they
create an
Archy okay you see how how the CLE works
and the C goes on and on and on these um
three factions always on conflict with
each other and their and and the way
they form their alliances creates a
certain form of government okay
when the nobility in charge is
anarchy when but then a king and the
people work together to overr and create
a
monarchy and then they uh and the King
becomes corrupt and so the nobility and
the people work together cre a democracy
okay and you can see the cycle happening
today United States as well right
because who is Trump trump is a king
does that make sense you guys what is
what what is Trump saying Trump is
saying to the people the elite are
corrupt the elite are stealing from you
the elite are lying to you vote for me
and I will destroy the elite and I will
give you more economic opportunities
okay do you understand so this is a
really important idea Trump is not going
to be president for four years his
ambition is to
be king okay and we see the cycle
throughout human
history so that's the idea of a
cycle
right we also have another model of
human history devel of human historical
development which is a line okay a line
and the idea of
progress towards
truth okay so that's the other competing
model okay there are two main models
there's a cycle and then there's a line
and the idea of the line is Human
Society does not go on and on in a
useless cycle it is moving towards a
truth is moving towards a good
end okay so then this idea has been
around for a very long time remember in
the
Bible the when um King David first
sponsored the the Bible the Bible was a
line where Yahweh the God he was looking
for a friend he was looking for someone
who he could trust to rule his kingdom
of heaven and he first tried Adam and
Eve and they disobeyed him then he tried
Noah then he tried Abraham and then he
tried Moses and then he found his true
friend who is David okay so the the
truth is
David in the Hebrew
Bible then you have the
Romans okay remember the Romans Virgil
wase something called the
inad and in the
inad um Troy was destroyed so that Rome
could be founded and when Rome was
founded Rome will have to fight the
series of wars that will eventually lead
to the rise of Augustus
Caesar and this will create something
called the Pax Romana and this is the
end of History this is where all
movement ends because once you achieve
the PX
Romana there'll be no more
war okay so it's idea of a lie obviously
this is not true but back then when they
came up with this history they thought
it was true and um if you know a little
bit about current history then you'll
know about a man named Francis fukayama
who is an American who works for the
government and he wrote something called
the end of History which is an essay
arguing um that when the Soviet Union
fell it showed the end of History before
history was a battle
ideas
communism capitalism and now with the
father Soviet Union we now
know that Western liberal consumer
democra Ry is the best system in the
world we no longer have to argue about
this everyone should try to be a liberal
consumer democracy including China and
if everyone became a consumer liberal
democracy there will be no more
war we would want to fight because we're
too busy spending
money and the best way they make money
is through trade not war okay we all we
now also know this is not true all
right but the
main
um proponents of the line theere of
History progress of History are actually
Christians okay Christians why
because they believe that Jesus marks a
turning point in history and and at the
and when Jesus came it marked a progress
towards truth what is truth truth is the
second coming of Jesus
which will Mark the end of the world
when Jesus
returns he will he will usher in a
millennium a thousand years of Peace
when he will be king we will all have to
obey him okay what I will show you in
the future when we discuss Crusades the
Crusades um is that this idea okay it
sounds like a simple idea but this idea
is what driving a lot of the conflict in
the Middle East believe it or not but
there are millions of Christians they're
call Christian zionists by the way who
want war in the Middle
East because if there's war in the
Middle East and the world is about to
end Jesus has to return from Heaven to
save
us okay you think this is silly you
think this is crazy but I'm telling you
right now
this idea which millions of people
around the world believe in it's one of
the main causes of the war in the Middle
East and guys crazy
ideas make crazy
events all right so there are people who
literally believe that we can save the
world by ending
it it's only a threat of nuclear
Holocaust it's it's only the threat of
the end of Israel that will force Jesus
to return issuing the second coming all
right now what's important for us to
understand is that these are the two
basic Frameworks of
history but there are variations to
these two basic models okay so for
example Hegel okay we'll discuss feder
Hegel later on in the semester he's he's
really important but he has this idea
called the
dialectic the dialectic dialectic just
means a conflict a conversation so what
he believes is that history is driven by
ideas that are conflict with each
other okay wherever there's an idea for
example let's say you have
capitalism then what will happen is a
new
idea will arise to ch challenge the
existing idea we'll call communism okay
and then what will happen is these two
ideas will merge
together and they will draw on the best
parts of each other and we can call this
socialism all right so it's a line okay
but it's it's it's like this almost
right there's a IDE there's there's an
idea something comes in conflict and it
and this leads to a new idea which then
leads to a new idea okay
but he still believes that we are
progressing towards the truth through
this
conflict all right so we'll discuss
Hegel and his theory of the dialectic um
later on the semester and this will lead
and this the idea of the dialectic will
lead to of course Marxism okay so Marx
is drawing a lot on hego and another
philosopher named um Emanuel Kant for
his theory of Communism but we'll do
that in later on in a semester all right
so these are the two
main models of historical development
you have the cycle the his Circle or the
line you either believe that things move
in continuous
motion or they're moving towards an
end okay does that make sense any
questions about these two models so far
okay
so what you will learn this semester is
a new model of historical
development okay it's a much more
complicated model than these two models
but I think it is much more useful in
helping us
predict the
causes
of um historical
development
okay
um I want to argue why these two
models don't really
work and it has to do with the fact that
history as an e economic discipline is
just not very good it's is not what I
mean by that
is you look at the world today there's
this Trump
presidency there's this conflict in the
Ukraine there's the Middle East conflict
and you would expect historians to come
out and say oh this has happened before
and we can then predict what will happen
and so this is what's going to happen
Okay but guess what guys they're not
doing that
also they're not very good at predicting
things they're just
not his history
has is
notorious for not being able for not
being able to tell us much about the
future and they St say well it's because
we look at the
past and for me this is frustrating
because if the history is any good if
the history is accurate then it should
help us predict the future or or at
least better understand the present okay
so the idea of Truth what is
truth well truth does two things first
explains why did this happen why did
World War II
start and the answer we have today is
like Hitler was a bad guy he was
evil okay that doesn't explain much for
us and then it also has to predict it
predicts if it's truthful then it
predicts and his she doesn't do
that so
I want to fix this problem by
introducing a new model of History which
is a lot more complicated okay I'll be
honest with you it's a lot more
complicated but I think for our purposes
it's more useful at explaining why
things happen the way they do and it's
helps us also predict what
happen okay and this model is what I
call the oceanic curve of
History imagine the world as a huge
ocean and within each ocean there's an
ecosystem which has
currents and then these currents come
into conflict with each
other which leads to a new development
okay so think about
hurricanes and the thing that's really
important about this model that I'm
proposing is there's no moral
judgment in it okay I mean obviously in
the line the end where we're going is
good and where we're at now is bad but
what I'm saying is this moral judgment
saying this is good this is bad it's not
helpful doesn't really tell us
anything all
right okay I'm much more interested in
explaining why this happened how this
happened and where this is going okay so
let's look at the world to understand
this Theory what I want what I want show
you is the world is divided into
cultural ecosystems okay cultural
ecosystems this is a really important
idea you you need to know for the rest
of
semester what I will argue is that
culture is the meta
reality meta reality
so what's meta reality meta reality is
the understanding the world from which
all other understandings
derive so what I'm saying is that
culture is the most important part of
who you are much more important than
your gender much more important than
your race your ethnicity much more
important than your
economic demographic okay you're rich
you're poor okay so to understand this
idea why culture so important I will do
a thought
experiment okay a thought experiment the
thought experiment is this let's take a
random guy from
China 2,000 years ago okay just a random
guy we take him off the streets and
we'll put him into China
today all right now
in 2000 years China has changed a lot
right we now have the internet we have
computers we have cell phones we have
skyscrapers we have cars we have roads
okay so China has changed a lot in these
2,000
years how long would it take him for him
to adapt to the New
China and might and I would say I would
say most 5 to 10
years because even though on the surface
China has changed a lot deep down inside
China's culture has stayed consistent
for the past 3 to 4 thousand years so he
he would understand how to make friends
he would understand if you were to get a
job how
to uh associate with his boss and his
colleagues if he would get to get to if
we would get married he would know how
to raise his children to have them
succeed in China okay does that make
sense to you guys
it would take him time to learn how to
use a cell phone and how to use a
computer and how to drive a car but he
can do so does that make
sense now let's do another experiment
let's take a random guy from China today
and put him in Germany today Germany
okay what I will argue is this he will
never ever be able to adapt to the the
culture he may get a job as a pizza
delivery man who knows okay but he will
never
ever make
friends who are German he won't find a
German
wife whatever job he does he won't know
how to succeed he won't know what to say
to his boss he won't know how
to associate with his boss okay does
that make sense this is a guy who knows
the internet who knows how to drive a
car who can who can speak English but
because of the culture he's always a
stranger does that make sense this
thought experiment I hope shows you the
Persistence of culture it's the most
important part of who you are it drives
everything else it drives how you see
the world it drives how you interact
with
others okay so what matters is
culture and nothing else and what I'm
what what I want to show you
is the semester is the world can be
divided into cultural ecosystems because
of the history because of the geography
because of the demographics okay does
that make sense so look
Europe is a cultural
ecosystem all right meaning someone from
Germany can go to Italy and still feel
at home they still they don't speak the
same language the geography is different
but they share the same cultural
orientation the same cultural values all
right someone who who lives in the
Middle East okay well some some call um
the
Levant Israel and other places okay but
basically the Middle East that's also
another cultural
ecosystem then you have
um uh the
steps so remember the steps are this
grassland this oce of grassland that
basically extends from Hungary to
Mongolia
okay and then you
have um China India okay so there
different these there these different
ecosystems cultural e systems that are
determined by their geography their
history and their
demographics and cultures
response to geography history and
demographics okay does that make sense
all
right now what I will show you
is
that within each
ecosystem they're always interacting
with each other okay they're always
interacting with each
other and when they
change they change their interaction
with each other all right
so let's ask a really important question
which is why do
Empires why do they fall why do they
climb why do they fail and this is a
really important
question how was it possible for the
Roman Empire to
collapse how were the Greeks able to
defeat the Persian
Empire how were the Mongolians the monus
able to C the Chinese
Empire all right and what I will show
you the semester is when this happens
when Empire is conquered
the pattern is the same there's a
consistent pattern in this all right so
let me explain the pattern and then for
the semester we'll go into specific
instances of this pattern to explore the
um specifics okay does that make sense
all right so what happens is this why
Empires fall is there's usually an
Empire okay let's just say
R and as they expand they encounter some
called the Borderlands okay
Borderlands Borderlands are just places
that are um the intersections of Empires
okay so Mongolia is the Borderland of
the Chinese Empire right Arabia is the
Borderland of the bantine and assassin
Persian Empires okay
and the Borderlands and the
Empire become at first simp
iotic okay meaning they depend on each
other they they work with each other
okay in three ways the first and the
first most simple way that they interact
is through
trade okay they trade with each other
second way they interact is
through um military corporation so what
often happens is the Empire needs
Mercenaries
and it turns out that people who live in
the Borderlands make very good soldiers
okay because they live in a time of war
and Chaos in the Borderlands there's no
Central Authority so they're always
fighting each other so they make very
good
soldiers and then the third way theya to
each other
is some people in the Borderlands will
raid and pillage the Empire the
outskirts of the empire for resources
okay so they are interacting with each
other
so the pattern is
this the Borderlands first start off as
as may an isolated region of the world
so
Arabia uh the
steps uh and the dramatic North okay
what we call Scandinavia today okay the
the the north the
northmen so these are all isolated Parts
but as the Empire expands they start to
interact with the
these isolated ecosystems and when they
act we and when they interact what
happens is these Borderlands become
energized okay they it's like the Empire
is adding fuel to the Borderlands by
giving them more wealth by giving them
more knowledge by giving them more
access to information okay does that
make
sense and over time what happens is
because of this new energy The Bard
lands become much more populated much
more wealthy much more
knowledgeable and then it creates
internal conflicts within their
Borderlands and the only way for them to
to to resolve this conflict is to
expand okay they have to expand now and
in the process of expand of expansion
what happens is now and then they will
conquer the Empire all right that's a
pattern
the Borderlands are first these isolated
regions that no one knows much
about they're like the stuff of Legend
and myth when the Empire
expands it energizes this these
Borderlands the energy makes these
Borderlands more wealthy more
populated and more militar sophisticated
that's creates conflicts within the
Borderlands too many people so what are
they forced to do they forced to expand
and dur the course of this expansion
they come in conflict with the Empire
and now and then they will conquer the
Empire become the new Empire that's a
pattern and it happens all over human
history okay this this is how the
Mongolians conquer China this is how the
M conquer China before the Mongolians
and mares conquer China there was
trade uh Chinese the Chinese Empire was
using them as
mercenaries okay there was also a lot of
small conflict does that make sense
all right so now that I explain the
pattern the question then is why would
this
happen why would this happen how is it
possible for the Borderlands which again
is only a
fraction of the wealth the population
and the resource of the
Empire how are they able to conquer the
Empire and this is a really important
lesson you will learn in this class
which is Empires are destined to
collapse
Empires must
collapse all
right so why is that the case in this
class you will learn there are three
boundary conditions of all
societies eventually all societies must
collapse for three reasons
all right the first reason
is Elite over
production second reason is rat
Utopia and the third reason
is
um uh
financialising the first
when a society first starts it's
important for people to contribute to
its growth right I can do that by
starting a farm when when I build a farm
I make Goods I'm creating W for the
society right you can also do that by
building a
factory but over time what happens is
you eventually realize that it's more
profitable for you to lend money than to
build things does that make
sense it's is much profitable much
easier for you
to um be a capitalist than is to be an
entrepreneur over
time so there's this very famous French
Economist his name is tominus
py and he wrote a book called um capital
in 21st century it's a very good book
um it's very easy to read and it's one
of the most discussed books right now
and he makes the argument he makes the
argument why inequality happens
inequality in society happens because of
the nature of
capital okay the nature of money what
money does is it seeks to grow for the
sake of growing and what's the best way
for Capital to grow by
consolidating and and charging
rents okay does that make sense so the
example is okay there are five
restaurants in Beijing they obvious
trying to compete against each other for
the for customers right so so they lower
prices and try to get better food but
eventually at some point they figure out
hey we're five restaurants man we can
just get together and negotiate a cartel
a deal where we charge all the all high
prices
right then we make more money that way
that's something we call Rent sinking
Behavior rent
sinking the idea of rent sinking is to
create a
monopoly which
forces people to buy whatever prices you
charge them okay that's the ultimate
goal of of Industry or Society or
business okay to engage in rcking
behavior and over time because Capital
consolidates it's much more
profitable to engage in capitalism than
is to engage in
entrepreneurship okay meaning you're
better off actually investing in the
stock market than you are in getting a
job in fact what he shows is
the return on
financial capitalism is 5% a year okay
on average if you put $100 in the start
Market you make
$5 all right but the return on the real
economy is only
2% meaning if you start a factory and
you hire people or you start a
restaurant which can which make which
contributes real growth real wealthy
economy you only make
2% all right and that's why if you go
to America and you will go to America
eventually you'll find that young people
your age they're not working what are
they doing they're investing in Bitcoin
they're playing the stock the real
estate
market they're investing in stocks do
you understand because it's you make
more money doing that then you do by
doing real work by creating a company
you understand
in other
words your
Society isn't producing any
value and as a result your economy can't
move on right does that make
sense and when you're in this situation
what are you forced to do
now if you're if you're society and you
want to continue what are you forced to
do EXC me open
what do you do historically what what
what have's done in order to get out of
this situation where
financialised your
Society make war guys you understand
because you make war you destroy things
you destroy things you are forced to
rebuild things it doesn't make
sense that's why we have
War because War means a game reset it
allows societ
to rebuild
itself okay so that's the first idea I
want you guys to understand over
time this the economy matures to a point
where Evan becomes a r renter okay or
sorry a rente you're trying to be a
landlord and you're trying to charge
people to use your land you don't want
to
work this this is true throughout the
world right in China it's the same thing
throughout Chinese history now in the
west it's the same thing as
well okay and at that point you have no
choice but to start a war to reset your
Society or your Society will continue to
decline okay so the first boundary
condition white societies Must Die
second bound boundary condition is the
idea of rat Utopia okay so we discussed
this a bit last semester I want to
refresh your memory rutopia is an
experiment
that's been done many times but the idea
is this what happens to rats in a
perfect
world normally rats have an extremely
ritual ritualized Society so for example
if you want to mate okay what male rats
do is they go on top of a mound where
all the female rats can see them right
and the Rats the male Rats start to
dance okay they did dance really
like um in a very strange way but that
attracts the attention of the
female the the male rat sees attention
to the female rat and the male rat
starts to chase the female rat the
female rat runs back into her burrow her
home and hides the male rat has to stand
outside and wait for the female rat to
come out when she comes out she will
start running again and he will start
chasing uh her and then she'll run back
into her Furrow again they do this
multiple times until eventually the
female rat lets him catch her and then
they will have sex and they'll be
married and have children okay so that's
rat society and it's no different from
Human Society right you like a girl or
you a or a boy you guys go out for a
coffee date then a lunch date and a
dinner date then eventually after a
couple years you might have sex and get
married and have children okay no
different it's a very heavily ritualized
Society what experimenters did was they
asked themselves what would happen
if we made a perfect world where no one
had to fight for food every day food
would come down from the heavens and all
the rats could do whatever they want
they would have complete Freedom this
what we call
ratopia it turned out
all sidey collapsed it was a complete
disaster the male Rats start to rape
female rats there's no more like playing
around there's no more ritual it was all
just rape and murder it was a complete
breakdown of
society why did this happen okay there
are many different theories but one
thing that you need to understand about
rats and humans is we all like status
status okay the idea is this we humans
we're all standing in line to go on onto
a mountain top okay the mountain top
everyone respects you you make a lot of
money you feel good about yourself and
we're all sing in line and this line
takes a long time but eventually you
will get to the mountain top this is how
this game works is people in the M top
have to fall off and die in order for
other people to CL up okay does that
make
sense but what happens when the people
the M top don't
die well you're just stuck in line when
you're stuck in line I'm not sure if
you've been stuck in line for like hours
and hours but you get angry right you
get frustrated so what do you do well
you hit someone behind you and then that
person gets angry and hits back hits you
back okay eventually that this line
everyone's fighting each other and
people at the mountain on top are
enjoying each other are enjoying the
view they have status and then they're
never going to die they're never going
to fall off and this is our society
today guys okay the people in power in
in China in the United States around the
world have been there for a long long
time and they're not dying so what are
young people doing tongue ping by line
right quite quitting lying flat because
you don't see any opportunities what you
want is not money what you want is
status and that we that we requires you
to achieve a certain level in
society but those positions are being
occupied by people who refuse to die and
as a result Society collapses young
people refuse to work they refuse to get
married and have children so your dies
you understand so rat Utopia is the
second boundary condition does that make
sense guys you're seeing this around the
world today all right ask yourselves why
is it that you yourself are not
motivated the answer is you really don't
see an
opportunity to climb to the top and
enjoy status you just don't because
people aren't dying they just not and
why because we've achieved a certain
level of abundance and wealth that
allows people to keep on
living okay does that make
sense any any questions before I
continue are you guys clear about this
and the third boundary
condition is the idea of elite
overproduction what is Elite
overproduction well it's the same as
radiotopia but radiotopia is a conflict
between the Hales and half knots Elite
over production is a conflict with among
the halves okay the very wealthy because
even though there's certain number a
limited number of status position
too many Elite people are being produced
okay so it's not only that the um
children of poor people are being
screwed over in the system it's the
children of the elite are being screwed
over in the system and this creates
conflict in the system because the poor
can't do anything they can just fight
each other in line but the elite can do
something they can go war against each
other they can monopol they can start
uh killing each other okay this creates
Civil War in
fact if you are to look at America today
you can say there's a civil war going on
between two different factions of the
elite okay does that make
sense and this is what drives a lot of
history where a lot of revolutions
happen not
because the poor are trying to overthrow
the rich it's because
the lower
nobility is fighting for opportunities
against the upper nobility does that
make sense guys okay we're seeing this
again today in China and also
in the United
States all right so these are the three
main boundary
conditions so now let's apply to these
three boundary
conditions and ask ourselves why Empire
is collaps well the first reason is
because most people in the Empire don't
want to live there they're just stuck
living there why do most people don't
want to live there because they are in
debt okay debt and
landlessness throughout most of human
history Empires that have persisted for
the longest have this huge problem where
the majority of the population suffers
from too much debt and suffers from too
much landlessness no
opportunities
okay then what happens is the elite
starts fighting amongst themselves
there's corruption why is there
corruption because the elite are
struggling to engage in R seeking
Behavior amongst themselves okay they're
trying to steal more they're stealing
more and more so there's corruption
there's civil conflict and there's
corruption
so it's only a matter of time before the
Empire
collapses but during this time what does
the Empire do okay it's really strange
and funny but what they do is this they
import the people from the Borderlands
in order to try to resolve their civil
conflicts they does that make
sense you can't trust the Army anymore
because the Army is made up of people
who have too much debt and who are
landless so what do you do you hire for
Mercenaries right that's what China does
or or that's what China did in its
history you can't trust your own Army so
you hire foreign mercenaries and
eventually what happens is you replace
your army with four Mercenaries
and
then eventually what happens the foreign
mercenaries take over your
Empire that's what happened in Rome
that's what
happened uh throughout human
history
okay okay so now that we've discussed
the Empire I want to look at the
Borderlands why is it
true that the
Borderlands are able to conquer the
Empire and my argument to you is
cultural it sorry culture it's cultural
all right so we have this Prejudice or
misunderstanding about civilization all
right
civilization civilization is about
cities it's about writing it's about
technology it's about wealth and if you
look looked at it that way then you
don't really understand why is it these
Borderlands the Mongolians among
Jews the Vikings the Arabians the Greeks
why are they able to conquer these
Empires that makes no sense to
you so what what I'm trying to say you
what what I'm trying to tell you is this
is a wrong way of looking at it a better
way of looking at is
culture in the Borderlands there's a
certain culture that develops because
it's a Borderland it's a it's a culture
that focuses on
freedom
egalitarianism and
self-reliance
Independence this is true throughout the
Borderland okay if you if we were to go
back to the Mongolia during the time of
gangas Khan if we were if we were to go
back to the the European north of the
time of
Vikings these are cultures that
emphasize freedom egalitarianism and
self-reliance and as
such these
were amazing Warriors
okay so let's let's look at example
let's look at the
um Vikings okay the Vikings didn't know
how to read or write they didn't have
any mathematics they didn't have
cities but from age two or three their
kids were learning how to swim how to
roll boats how to cook how to hunt how
to fight how to ride horses does that
make
sense and what what are civilized kids
doing they're learning how to do test
questions
right in a war who's going to win well
obviously these
guys okay does that make
sense so these are the this is the idea
of the O Oceanic currents okay you have
these isolated
areas that are ecosystems amongst
themselves as the Empire expands okay
just think of it as a current the
emperial Curr current it's expanding
expanding that's what Empires do it
energizes these areas and these areas
actually have much more energetic
potential than the Empire which is dying
okay and this energy forces so much
energy in this Borderlands that they are
now become like a hurricane and they
have to ride through history some
they're defeated but
sometimes like the
Greeks like the Vikings
like the
Mongolians like the
Arabians they win and when they
win they create a lot of Destruction
okay and that's the idea I want
implanted in your head these are
currents these are natural forces that
are unstoppable once they start you
cannot stop
them okay this war in Ukraine it is a
hurricane that will engulf all of Europe
this war in the Middle East is a
hurricane that will engulf the entire
world once this starts you can't have a
conference and decide to end it it these
things cannot end until they reach your
natural course okay the hurricane stops
when it runs out of energy does that
make
sense the hurricane does not negotiate
with you and said oh well um you make a
very good case for why I shouldn't
destroy you so I'll just stop hurricanes
don't do that these are natural
forces right and this is what I will
show you this semester and I I will also
show you how this connects to current
events and then once we do that we
should be able to predict current events
and just let you know spoiler
alert things will not end well okay okay
we are looking at the complete under
destruction of the world we live in
today nothing will be the
same because these
are Oceanic currents they destroy
against path once you unleash them they
must
destroy it's only a question of how
much
right all
right was this clear to you guys any
questions
anything you want anything you want me
to clarify or elaborate again I know
this is a big Theory but we will be
doing a lot of examples throughout the
course of the semester all right and
this will give you a unified theory of
history and you'll see how everything
everything connects
together right any questions
oh that's a good question okay what
starts these hurricanes or what starts
this process all right so if you look at
an ocean you will discover that these
currents are happening all the time you
understand there there's no start
they're always in
motion all right so once you start an
Empire you're starting already to
unleash a hurricane in the Borderlands
once the hurricane matures in the
Borderlands it will overwhel an Empire
which will then start to energize a new
Borderland does that make sense so
that's a that's that's a really good
question uh and unfortunately the um the
answer is there will always be
hurricanes hurricanes are always forming
you just have to figure out where
they're forming in order to predict
where where they're coming from okay but
obviously the two big hurricanes right
now are what's happening
um in Ukraine and what's happening in
Israel in the Middle East okay but um
other her are are coming okay uh for
example there will eventually be a
conflict in East Asia all right now A
lot of people are saying the conflict
will be
between um China United States I do not
think that's the case I do not
think um the conflict will be between
United States and China I think it will
involve Japan and South
Korea all right it will not be over the
Taiwan straight it will be between it
will involve South Korea and Japan how
so I don't really know okay another
conflict is what's happened in America
America um is itself a hurricane
eventually America will have to fight a
Civil War and when you go to America you
will see how divided the country
is all right and people are already
predicting a civil war it's the only
question of when I think things will
speed up in 2028 the reason why is um
the election in 2028 will be heavily
contested people are going to argue over
who won and it'll be very clear who won
in 2028 and there's a very good chance
Trump will run again in
okay but I but I think these are two big
Hans that are coming along the way not
now but they're coming along the way um
the the big scary hurricane of course is
Iran okay eventually United States and
Iran will come in conf with each in will
come in conflict with with each other
okay and this will drag in the entire
world right does does that make sense to
you Eva okay thanks for the question
okay any more questions
[Music]
until it overwhelms the
Empire that that's a great question okay
all right so we have to figure out what
is driving the hurricane and the answer
is the internal conflicts within the
Borderlands does that make sense so
there's just too many people and there's
just not enough status positions so they
go on and they conquer their own
territory right so you look at the
Vikings okay the Vikings the Vikings are
interesting the Vikings which we'll
discuss a lot they're in northern Europe
and for most of human history we had
actually no idea they were there okay
they were in the North in Denmark in
Norway in Sweden and they basically kept
themselves they still traded the world
but we didn't really know know much
about them okay and then they started to
come out of
nowhere and they did three things they
went over to colonize Greenland and
Iceland all right and they also went to
actually North America so they were
actually the first Europeans to reach
North America so one Str sh that they
had was to expand and explore and
colonize okay but then you also had a
group of Vikings northmen who went to
attack France and they were so such a
huge problem that the French decided to
give them their own land called
Normandy okay Normandy the land of the
north people Normandy
all right and then they went over here
to
Ukraine uh along the uh River because
they were trading with the Islamic
empire and they found it colonies or new
new settlements and this was a peaceful
process okay because they were trying to
establish Trading Post and this became
the basis of which country you guys know
Russia okay you see people will call the
Roose I actually don't know what Roose
means but it just means Rose and that's
where Russia comes from so this
beginning of a new country called Russia
all right and Normandy is interesting
because they eventually went off to
conquer a new country called you guys
know who they conquered who who who do
the Normans
conquer 1066 guys
England Britain all right he
that so the herin stops when the people
just run out energy because they've
reached the point where they can't go on
okay the hurrian create is created
because they have wealth power but they
don't have enough status positions so
they have to expand to fill the status
positions okay this is this is actually
what drives Empire Building does that
make
sense it's not because you lack
resources it's because you have too many
people who want status and you can't
fill fill them you can't let leave them
in your Society because then they will
overthrow you so you send them somewhere
else
okay all right good is that clear eeko
great any more
questions great okay so uh I I hope this
was clear we will
continue discussing this throughout the
throughout the semester because this
becomes the framework for which we
understand all of European history for
the past 2,000 years okay so next class
we will do the Roman Empire the fall and
decline of the Roman Empire which will
lead us into the rise system called the
Holy Roman Empire which is not the Roman
Empire okay it's basically the French
Empire okay or the um Frankish Empire
and the Frank Empire will lead to the
rise of the
Vikings all right all right so those are
next three classes all right great